the Battle Star Galactica new TV series
reboot reimagine whatever the hell we're
going to get is back on track but where
are we now what do we know and what has
Sam esmail the showrunner been saying
welcome to serek your Sci-Fi TV I'm
Movie Channel so about six months ago I
actually told you guys that it really
did look like the TV series and the
movie that were planned to bring Battle
Star Galactica back were in trouble and
probably weren't going to happen
basically during the strikes a lot of
projects were put on the back burner and
it really didn't look like Battle Star
Galactica was going to really get going
again it still looks like the movie
stuck in development hell and I'm still
again being told by sources reasonably
close to the area that it may not happen
but plans for the TV series have been
reignited and the peacock network is
planning to do a pilot now this is the
first first thing I'm going to talk
about that has changed massively and
this was not the original plan two years
ago when Sam esmail first started
talking about this he was saying this
was going to be a 10 episode run direct
to streaming so we were not looking at
getting a pilot at that point so why are
we now well this comes down in part to
the strikes and the delays to the TV
series but also there's just been a
massive overspending in recent years on
streaming Services streaming services
just straight out the door ordering 10
episodes of something without doing
their normal practice of a pilot to
basically see one episode see how it
works see if they want to make any
changes and then ordering the rest of
the series well in this case it looks
like originally they were just going to
go with what streaming services have
been doing the last few years and just
throwing money at the series but now
they've had a bit of a rethink and looks
like they've decided to go with a pilot
instead Sam esmail the showrunner has
been talking about how they are nearly
ready to go to Pilot and he says it'll
probably be quite soon again talk to my
sources I can tell you that by quite
soon he means the new year and really
currently they're just looking at
finalizing the script and that they are
hoping that basically by March they'll
be looking for a studio and actually
doing those practical things of getting
ready to shoot a lot of casting
apparently is already in a preliminary
stage and they're really hoping to get
going within three or four months and
what else do we know well Sam esmail was
also talking about how the 2004 Ronald E
Moore version of Battlestar Galactica
really did focus on society's post 911
anxieties and Sam basically thinks that
the Battlestar Galactica story can can
be used to reflect modern anxieties
particularly that of AI now we've heard
a lot about AI in the last few years I
saw an advert just a couple of days ago
where apparently a Hoover uses AI
technology to decide what type of flaw
your hoovering if that isn't the start
of the end of the world I don't know
what is because apparently my Hoover has
Ai and is going to turn itself against
me I'm going to get suck to death that
sounds wrong but I'm sticking with it if
you like what we're doing over here on
Sid Trek then don't forget obviously to
subscribe and hit the Bell notification
so you never miss any of our videos but
also hit a thumbs up and drop a comment
it really helps with those pesky little
YouTube algorithms so AI is everywhere
at the moment and obviously during the
actors and the writers strikes we heard
an awful lot about it I think we're
going to be hearing even more and more
over the next 10 years or so as this new
technology that isn't even technically
AI it's not technically artificial
intelligence but it's getting close
we're going to be hearing more and more
about this technology in the next decade
as it's perfected so why is Sam asmail
talking about this now again through my
sources I've been able to actually find
out exclusively and first that actually
they had a script for 10 episodes and
that script during the strikes was
completely thrown out Sam asmail was
asked by the studios to completely start
again and he's done so they've pretty
much got a pilot script ready and that's
ready to go um but the rest of the
season is now really up for debate they
have completely restarted and reimagined
the series and that actually leads into
my next point where initially s asmail
was talking about that this show would
actually exist within universe of the
original Battle Star Galactica now he
was always a little bit vague on what
that meant because it's not necessarily
going to be a continuation
it was going to be within Universe
though I told you um in a video um just
six or seven weeks ago actually that
there was a rumor this was going back
about 18 months and actually this new
series by samma would be a be a little
bit of a prequel that it was going to be
based and start around the launch of the
battl Star Galactica and that it was
going to tell the story of the Galactica
how did this vessel become so well-
loved and well respected within the 12
colonies why was she being turned into a
museum at the point of being
decommissioned how had she earned such a
incredible
reputation that's what this series is
going to be based on now I don't know if
that's still the point but Sam ismael's
language about what this show will be
has changed slightly instead of saying
that it's going to exist within the
universe Ronald E Moet he's now saying
they're trying not to step on the toes
too much of Ronald D Moore's version
so no longer within Universe perhaps it
has been nearly 20 years since Ronald De
Moore's Battle Star Galactica series I
actually can't believe that it's been 20
fracking years I am so old so they
obviously feel that maybe rebooting or
reimagining sections at least of that
storyline might now be okay and if the
movie isn't going ahead they don't have
to worry about stepp on the toes of that
either so it does look like that they
have had a pause had a rethink and
actually started again now the last
Point here is that Sam esmael was always
supposed to be showrunning this project
he's now saying that he's actually not
going to necessarily be doing that he's
still going to be an executive producer
he's still going to be in and around the
project and he's still going to be
acting as maybe the boss as the final
word but he's now saying they're going
to be getting the top t talent in to
support this TV show he says I don't do
hardcore sci-fi this is not really my
area so we're going to get the right
people in to do this Justice now again
sources that I speak to have said
there's a couple of possibilities for
that and I'm going to very quickly say
they don't know for certain but they've
basically said look there's a couple of
possibilities either the executives over
at the peacock Network have said look
Sam is this really your bag can you do
this or do we need to get people in to
support you or more likely that because
the show has been put on hold for so
long because of the strikes Etc Sam
esmail has other projects he's
contracted to do and simply won't have
time to do them both so they're going to
have to bring in other people to support
him and he will basically just act as an
overall manager to the project so he's
not leaving it completely but he's going
to be allowing others to take a lot of
the weight I suspect that is probably
more likely I think think a lot of this
decision has probably come from Sam
himself as well basically saying look I
can do this this and this I want the
show to still be my baby but I do need
somebody in here that understands the
genre a little bit better than me so
guys get into the comments and tell me
what you think is this project something
you're looking forward to and actually
if it is a reboot basically a hard
reboot even maybe that ignores the
Ronald D Mo version would that be a good
thing or a bad thing it is really
started to feel a little bit like Batman
with Battlestar Galactica we don't
really need to be told the origin story
again do we or actually has it been so
long now since Ronald De Mo's version
and a version that let's be honest
started
magnificently the miniseries is sci-fi
Perfection as far as I'm concerned but
as the series developed it wandered a
little bit and I have to admit I stopped
watching it I I came back back to it
years later but first time around I got
bored of it I'd love to know actually
what you thought of the Battlestar
Galactica series particularly as the
series went on and you know the failed
prequel series does Battle Star
Galactica actually deserve a second
chance and maybe Ronald D Mo's 2004
version was a little bit of a missed
opportunity get into the comments and
tell me exactly what you think if you
are new to the Channel please like
subscribe hit that Bell notification it
really helps us out you'll never miss
any of our new videos also you can go to
patreon.com cirre where most of our
videos Premier first you can also go to
c.co do.uk which is our dedicated
website and we try to do articles based
on most of our videos and we try to add
a little bit more information for you to
digest go over and check it out as
always please stay safe and I'll see you
next
time